good morning believe nation today's
messages take the small steps that lead
to greatness
over to you Eckhart Tolle a TV soap if
many people have this idea I want to
achieve something great or be somebody
great and they neglect the step that
leads to greatness they don't honor this
step in this moment because they have
this idea of some future moment where
they're going to be great right some
people believe I'm doing great work I
mean I am because the consciousness is
moving through this form I don't feel
personally responsible for what I do
it's not but even there it is small
steps when the writing happens is a
notepad and a pen unless the present
moment and this is stillness very small
is not some idea I'm going to create a
work that's going to change everybody's
consciousness no I'm just true to this
moment what is this moment requires it's
a blank piece of sheet of paper and a
pen and the stillness it's a small thing
it's all the sequence of very small
moments and by being true to this small
moment something great arising so this
is a message I believe in and I've
talked a lot about on this channel I
think too many people just want to take
giant leaps forward and they don't
recognize that in order to take those
big leaps you have to take a lot of
small steps and if you look at anything
great that you've ever accomplished in
your life what are the biggest things
that you've done in your business in
your personal life chances are if you
look back on them they were just a
collection of a lot of small steps that
happened that when you look back and
look why I did this great big thing but
it's just a collection of a lot of small
steps and a lot of people don't want to
do the work of the small steps and I
just want to hit that big thing and for
me it comes back down to you have to
enjoy the process you have to enjoy the
work that you do you have to enjoy the
grind so it doesn't feel like a grind
right
I am grinding on YouTube every single
day
I'm grinding on YouTube making videos
answering comments making private videos
practicing researching and that allows
me and my team to have the consistency
that we have right who else is
publishing three to four videos a
quality every day
but for me it doesn't feel like a grind
I love Wednesdays which is my video
recording day I love the day that I do
the research I love the day that I'm
doing improvement of the videos I love
the work it may seem like a grind to you
guys if you stepped into my business and
had to do the things that I was doing
you might get quickly overwhelmed and
say man I can't that's too much work I
can't do it does it feel like work to me
I love it I love doing this Wednesday's
one of my favorite days of the week and
so you need to find that thing for
yourself were those little steps that
you have to take every day to accomplish
some great thing that little step feels
like love to you you love doing those
little steps it brings you joy you can't
wait to go out and do it again and
something can enjoy every step not every
day is going to be amazing you're gonna
have some crap that you have to deal
with and a lot of it but net-net you've
got to love your business and the actual
work and not just being attached to the
goal not for me just trying to hit a
million subscribers or tell me ten
million subscribers or whatever it is
not just me attached to that revenue
goal or that vacation target or want to
buy that car right if that's your only
purpose you're going to fail you'll
never get there but it's enjoying the
process along the way
stop being so focused on the destination
and enjoy the journey that's the secret
of success and entrepreneurship so the
question today today is I'm curious what
do you guys do that is a grind that
would feel like a big grind for other
people stepping into your business where
they would look at you said I can't do
that but for you it makes you come alive
what is that what's that special thing
in your company leave in the comments
below I'm going to join in the
discussion I also want to give a quick
shout out to Daniel Mattingly Daniel
thank you so much for buying a copy of
my book it really means a lot to me but
these are guys watching if you want to
change at a shadow in a future video
make sure to pick up a copy of the book
really
I promise and email in your receipt so
that we can keep track and send you the
bonuses thank you guys so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe or whatever your one word is and
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot events press L away spray
so keep ego